the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi we've sort of arrived that d-day in
our course that in a manner of speaking
everything that we've done up to now has
been a rehearsal that today we are going
to come to grips with what the course is
all about namely a real-valued function
of several real variables and before
getting into that what I'd like to do is
to review very briefly what we've talked
about so far in terms of functions since
we've introduced the vector notation
namely what we've mentioned this is that
our function machine could have either a
vector or a scalar as its input and
either a vector or a scalar as its
output part one of our course centered
around the idea where both the input and
the outputs were scalars whereas the
previous block of material concerned the
case where our input was a scalar and
our output was a vector today what we're
going to discuss is the situation that
occurs when our input is a vector and
our output is a scalar and I call
today's lecture n-dimensional vector
spaces eventually we'll discuss vector
spaces in more detail for the time being
I simply want to set the mood and
hopefully by the time I'm through show
you a rather peaceful coexistence
between the worlds of the new
mathematics and the worlds of
traditional mathematics in fact in many
of our topics that we're going to tackle
in this block of material we will give
both points of view but to set the stage
properly to get into the idea of what a
vector space is all about and if that
word frightens you just don't worry
about it for another to worry about
after that but let's just get started
here let's consider the situation where
I have a function machine where my input
is a vector and my output is a scalar as
an example let me just generically let V
represent the vector whose form is X I
plus YJ
I and J components let me define F of V
to be pi times the square of the I
component times the J component and
let's not worry right now about why I
pick this particular recipe let's simply
observe that once this recipe is chosen
F is a function which Maps a
two-dimensional vector here in I and J
components into a number PI x squared Y
just to illustrate this recipe notice
that if I vector with three I plus four
J the output of the F machine if this
were the input would be what pi times
the square of the first component the
component of I that's three squared
times the component of J which is four
and that leads to 36 pi by the way
observed that order does make a
difference namely if I reverse the roles
of the coefficients and feed the vector
F for I plus 3 J into my F machine the
output would be pi times 4 squared the
square of the I component u C times 3
and that would be 48 pi notice also that
we have allowed already in our course
the abbreviation that a comma B would
represent a AI plus BJ or a comma B
comma C would represent AI plus BJ plus
CK the idea is that if we now apply this
shorthand notation to these two vectors
what we could say is what F of this
vector notice F of 3 comma 4 is 36 PI
whereas f of 4 comma 3 is 48 pi and
that's exactly what we mean when we say
that we may treat a two-dimensional
vector as an ordered pair you see it's
not only a pair but the order does make
a difference both in what the vector is
and on what the output of the F machine
is ok hopefully let's say so far so good
and let's tackle now a rather complete
different problem what I'd like to do
now is the following
let's consider the cylinder right
circular cylinder the radius of whose
base is X and whose height is y notice
that the volume of this cylinder is PI x
squared Y and if I use the same F that
we used previously in other words the
same f that we were talking about over
here notice that another way see how is
F defined given that the input was X
comma Y the output was PI x squared Y
notice that the volume is f of X Y in
particular if I want the volume of the
cylinder the radius of whose base is a
is 3 and whose height is 4 see X is 3
and Y is 4
when I really want is F of 3 comma 4
that's pi times 3 squared times 4 F of 3
comma 4 is 36 PI now I'd like to pause
for a second again and return to our
earlier remark namely if I look at this
and if I look at this
notice that these two expressions are
identical
I cannot tell the difference between
whether I'm looking at the vector 3i
plus 4j or whether I'm looking at the
cylinder the radius radius of whose base
is three and whose height is four
whether I look at this equation or
whether I look at this equation the
difference is that in the first case
somehow or other it was quite natural to
think of three comma four as being
either an ordered pair or an arrow in
this case however my contention is that
when we think of the radius of the base
of the cylinder and the height we do not
tend to think in terms of arrows but
rather in terms of ordered pairs in
other words the ordered pair X comma y 4
in the expression f of XY need not be
viewed as an arrow but as an ordered
pair and an ordered pair is called a
2-tuple in fact this leads to a
generalization that I think is rather
important and I think you will see in a
moment where the idea of this approach
comes into functions of several real
variables the topic I have in mind is
something called an n-tuple
and let me read into that rather
gradually as follows without giving you
a specific physical example meaning I'll
give you an illustration but leave the
numerical amounts out quite possibly if
I'm studying temperature in a room the
temperature willing in general what it
will depend on what position I'm in at
the room and also at what time I measure
the temperature in other words it's fair
to assume that in many applications the
temperature is some function of the four
independent variables X Y Z and T where
x y and z are the Cartesian coordinates
of three-dimensional space and T
represents time at any rate what I'm
driving at is I can now visualize this
in terms of my function machine
again namely to compute T I think of
feeding what specific values into the
machine for X Y Z and T the F machine
then performs on X Y Z and T as
indicated by F to compute T in other
words again the input of my F machine in
this case is what I'm going to call a
four tuple for the time being
namely I need four values X Y Z and T
order does make a difference for example
if I interchange the X and the y
coordinate those x and y what I'm doing
is is I'm interchanging the X and the y
coordinate of the point in space and
that in general is going to change the
point in space the point however is that
in this particular F machine
notice that my output is a scalar namely
the temperature is a number but the
input is a fourth tuple namely X Y C T
now the trouble with using symbolism
like X Y Z and T well I guess without
going into a long philosophic discussion
among other things as soon as you have
27 or more independent variables you run
out of letters in the alphabet as a
result it is quite common for one to
adopt a new notation namely instead of
saying that X Y Z T be a fourth double
what one usually does is chooses one
symbol say X and then uses subscripts
namely a general for topple would have
the form 1 X 1 comma X 2 comma X 3 comma
X 4 where X 1 X 2 X 3 and X 4 are
numbers and an expression like this is
called a four topple what is this a
generalization of the fourth couple is a
generalization of the one-dimensional
two-dimensional and three-dimensional
arrows so to speak where we could think
of what the vector X 1 I as just needing
one member one number to specify it the
vector X 1 I plus X 2 J could have been
used to do what
could've been abbreviated by the two
tupple x1x2
and the vector X 1 I plus X 2 J plus X 3
K could have been abbreviated by the
three typo X 1 X 2 X 3 it is
conventional in 1 2 or 3 dimensional
space to use XY and Z instead of x1 x2
and x3 but that's just a convention I
think that it's because we learnt it
that way that we do it in general I
think this the subscript notation is
much nicer but in general the idea is
what given an ordered array of n numbers
x1 up to xn we call that an n-tuple and
my friend and colleague John Fitch
mentioned to me that if n is odd like 1
3 5 or 7 then it's known as an odd
couple which isn't a very funny story I
guess that's why I told you John told me
that particular story but the whole idea
is look at this is an N couple and the
whole idea again is what that an end up
will make sense even when n is greater
than 3 the whole name of the game are
functions of several real variables in
terms of modern mathematics in terms of
the language of n tuples is that a real
valued function of several whereby
several you mean more than one real
variables is simply a function in which
the input is an n double and the output
is a number ok that's what this whole
thing is all about and because of that
when we then abbreviate the N tuple we
use X with a bar under it let's call it
X bar rather than X with the arrow over
it since arrows may be inappropriate now
what do I mean by inappropriate or I
mean that even in the case of one two or
three dimensions you might be thinking
of say the radius and the height of a
cylinder rather than as an arrow and in
more than three dimensions for most of
us at least it's difficult to visualize
what we would mean by an arrow so we
just use the bar underneath now again
the major point is notice this
I keep saying the major point I guess
there's a lot of major points about this
remember that we did not call arrows
vectors we did not call arrows vectors
until we defined a structure on the
arrows remember what we did we told what
it meant for two arrows to be equal we
told how we added two arrows and we told
how we multiply the narrow by a scalar
in a similar way we will not call n
tuples a structure until we tell how to
equate a pair of n tuples how to add a
pair and how to multiply an n-tuple by a
number by the way the structure that we
wind up with is then called an
n-dimensional vector space or more
concisely n space and the idea works
like this let's pick a particular value
of n which is called n and let S sub n
be the set of all n tuples x1 up to xn
in other words a set of what all n
tuples of numbers x1 up to xn let's pick
two particular members of S sub n which
we'll call a bar and B bar where a bar
is simply an abbreviation for a the N
tuple a 1 up to a n with the a 1 a 2 up
to a n etc are real numbers and B bar is
an abbreviation for the end couple B 1
etcetera BN where B 1 up to B through BN
are also real numbers now again here's
where structure comes into play we have
already defined and n tuple arithmetic
in terms of arrows for the case that n
is either 1 2 or 3 namely based on what
happens when n is 1 2 or 3 we invent the
following definitions first of all we
invent the definition that a bar equals
B bar means that the components meaning
what the individual members of the
uncouple the components of a bar are
equal to the components of B bar
component by component in other words a
1 is equal to B 1 a 2 is equal to B 2
etc all the way up to what ANZ
to be n-now other words again what we're
saying is that for two n-tuples to be
equal by definition they should be equal
component by component and this is
motivated by the fact that we already
know that we've accepted this structural
definition for the case of arrows
similarly given two n-tuples
a bar and B bar to add them let me
define that to be the end couple that I
get by adding component by component in
other words to find the first component
of a bar plus B bar I add the first
component of a bar to the first
component of B bar noticing of course
that this is what B carefully this is
one number a 1 plus B 1 is 1 number a 2
plus B 2 is a number a n plus B n is a
number in other words notice that by
this definition the sum of two n-tuples
is again an n-tuple and finally to
multiply a scalar by an n-tuple i will
agree to define that definition to mean
that you multiply the n-tuple component
by component by that particular scalar
or number notice again that all I have
done here is I have obtained these three
structural definitions from the
equivalent situations of arrows and
since everything that was true about
arrows followed from these three basic
definitions any set of n tuples that
obeys this particular structure will
also behave like the arrows did and
that's why we call it a vector space
they behave like vectors even though
they can no longer be viewed as arrows
and again there are creative people who
view these things as arrows I remember
feeling very intimidated one day by my
undergraduate professor the first time I
learnt vector spaces and I said how do
you visualize an n-dimensional vector
space and in full seriousness without
batting an eyelash he says I visualize
it like a porcupine with a bunch of
quills coming out of it and I knew that
he knew where who is
like but didn't help me one bit I'm
saying if you can visualize these things
as arrows be my guest
feel free to do so if you can't notice
that every one of these definitions
stands on its own two feet subject to
the condition that when n is 1 2 or 3 we
happen to have a very nice geometric
interpretation by the way I may have
given you the impression that vector
spaces were invented because of
functions of several variables rather
the impression I would like to leave you
with is that in terms of motivating
vector spaces in terms of this course
that was the motivation that we elected
to use that the mathematician talked
about vector spaces in many a different
contexts from what we might even dream
possible in other words I don't have to
think of temperature being a function of
the four variables X Y Z and T let me
give you a different kind of non-trivial
example of a fourth space that doesn't
even bring functions into play let's
suppose I invent the abbreviation of I
write the fourth couple a 0 a 1 a 2 a 3
to denote the cubic polynomial a 0 plus
a 1 X plus a 2 x squared plus a 3 X
cubed in other words notice that I can
use these as a place value system namely
the first member tells me my constant
term the second member tells me the
coefficient of x the third member tells
me the coefficient of x squared and the
fourth member gives me the coefficient
of x cubed notice that for two
polynomials to be identically equal they
must be equal what coefficient by
coefficient that means what component by
component how do we add two polynomials
we add them coefficient by coefficient
we add like terms in other words given
two polynomials we add them what
component by component we add the two
constant terms together the two
coefficients of X together the two
coefficients of x squared together the
two coefficients of X cubed together you
see how do we multiply a polynomial by a
scalar we multiply each term by the
scalar that in turn is equivalent for
multiplying each coefficient by that
scale
and that says in terms of n purple
notation that we have multiplied each
component by that scalar in other words
the set of polynomials of degree n forms
a very nice
vector space in terms of our definition
of a vector space now of course the
danger is that one gets the idea that
any set of n tuples can be viewed as a
vector space an n-dimensional vector
space but this we have to be careful
about remember it is not the end tuples
it is the structure that they obey let
me give you sort of a simple example
over here let me consider the following
situation first of all let me just
emphasize the statement I just made it
let me just read it with you n tuples
are not automatically n spaces for
example let me invent the abbreviation
the two tupple a comma B to represent
the number a plus B for example if I
define the two couple a comma B to be an
abbreviation for a plus B what would
four comma 5
Deno remember the two table means what
to get the value of the two couple is
just the sum of the components if I add
a and B in this case four plus five
happens to be nine how about the two
type of six comma three what value would
that have that would also have the value
9 therefore numerically the two type of
4 comma 5 is equal to the tuple 6 comma
3 yet notice that the first component
here is not equal to the first component
here in other words 4 is not equal to 6
nor is 5 equal to 3 but if I were to
choose this definition of equality I
could not say that these two tuples
formed a 2-dimensional vector space
because it violates the first definition
for a vector space namely the definition
of what it means for two vectors to be
equal at any rate since we're going to
let most of our material be covered by
the exercises and the supplementary
notes and this is just to be an overview
let's move on now let's assume that we
now know what what n-dimensional vector
spaces are like we now know that we can
view functions of several
variables as functions that map n-tuples
into numbers and as a result it now
makes sense to talk about things like
suppose you were given the end couple X
1 X 2 X 3 X 4 and suppose that by under
F that end taboo was mapped into X 1
cubed plus X 2 plus X 3 squared plus 2 X
4 for example if I were to replace X 1
by 1 X 2 by 3 X 3 by 1 and X 4 by 2 I
would arrive at the result what 1 cubed
plus 3 plus 1 squared plus 2 times 2 and
I can compute that output now the
question that comes up in calculus is
can we talk about limits here instead of
computing what f of 1 comma 3 comma 1
comma 2 is can I compute the limit of
this thing as X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 approaches
1 comma 3 comma 1 comma 2 now I think
intuitively it's clear that since
equality means that you must have
equality component by component to say
that this approaches this means that the
first component here must approach the
first component here the second
component here approaches the second
component here etc in other words this
could be replaced by the fourth separate
linear one-dimensional limit problems X
1 approaches 1 X 2 approaches 3 X 3
approaches 1 and X 4 approaches 2 and we
would then be tempted to say what we
will replace X 1 by 1 X 2 by 3 X 3 by 1
X 4 by 2 see what happens to this
expression and we would be then be
tempted to say that this particular
limit was equal to 9 now the interesting
point is this that traditionally this
particular problem was tackled long
before anyone invented vector spaces or
at least long before anybody was serious
about vector spaces namely people did
say why can't we reduce the study of 4
dimensional space to four separate
studies of 1 dimensional space
in other words that x1 approach 1 x2
approach 3 in that case you're allowing
what four separate one-dimensional
limits to be taking place here but the
insight that modern math gave us was
that we can now go back to our
traditional definition of limit remember
what was our old structural definition
of limit way back from the first time we
had it the limit of f of X as X
approaches a equals L means given
epsilon greater than 0 we can find Delta
greater than 0 such that whenever the
absolute value of X minus a is greater
than zero but less than Delta the
absolute value of f of X minus L is less
than Epsilon now here's what the new
math said the modern approach said look
let's just take our old structural
definition the same as before and
vectorize everything notice in this
situation that we're dealing with the
input is where we have the several
variables the input is the n-tuple the
vector okay and the output is the scalar
so f is a scalar l is a scalar but X and
ay are vectors so every place I see an X
and an a I have to put the bar
underneath and now I read this
definition and all of a sudden as so
often has happened in our course up to
now I come to something that I've never
seen before
namely as soon as I look at this this
made very good sense when these were
arrows namely we talked about this
earlier in our course in one of our
lectures that the Sailor two arrows were
near each other was to say that their
difference was small and that in turn
said if the arrows were placed tail to
tail we could make the distance between
their heads as small as we wish now the
price that we have to pay for higher
dimensions is that if we have more
dimensions than what we can draw arrows
in the problem that we're faced is that
we have not defined what you mean by the
magnitude of X minus a where X and a
happen to be n tuples and here again we
come back to our structure but now for
the first time the structure is not
redundant let me tell you what I mean by
that in the one-dimensional
case we define the magnitude of X minus
a to be the square root of x 1 minus a 1
squared where the vector X was the one
tupple X 1 and the vector a was the N
tuple X a 1 in the two-dimensional case
we said okay let's define the magnitude
of the vector X minus a to be X 1 minus
a 1 squared plus X 2 minus a 2 squared
and in the three dimensional case we
said let's define the magnitude of X bar
minus a bar to be the square root of x 1
minus a 1 squared plus X 2 minus a 2
squared plus X 3 minus a 3 squared now
at that time I kept saying look at
notice that these recipes do not depend
on a picture that these are numerical
results that we could compute without
having to draw a picture at all what
happened of course was that in the
one-dimensional case in the two
dimensional case in the three
dimensional case it was easier to
visualize the picture now here's where
the real kicker comes in and this is the
real crucial point structurally can't
you see what's happening over here
can't you see how I can now define the
absolute value of the vector X bar minus
a bar even if n is greater than 3 in
such a way that the definition will make
sense and still mimic everything that
we're doing in fact I hope you are a
step ahead of me on this except for some
new notations I introduced here it turns
out that in the modern math book one
distinguishes between the absolute value
of a number and the magnitude of a
vector and it is frequently traditional
to introduce a double bar on each side
to represent the magnitude of the
difference between two vectors which I
claim behaves like a distance let me
show you what I mean by that let me
define the magnitude of the N tuple X
bar minus the N tuple a bar written this
way to be the positive square root of x
1 minus a 1 squared
plus etc plus xn minus a n squared the
thing that I would like you to notice
here is that since each of these numbers
are non-negative see their squares of
real numbers the only way this can be 0
well the only way that the sum of
squares of non-negative numbers can be 0
is for each of the numbers to be 0
consequently the only way the magnitude
of X bar minus a bar can equal 0 is if X
1 equals a 1 X 2 equals a 2 etcetera xn
equals a n in this vein notice that the
geometric phrase x bar near a bar still
makes sense it doesn't make sense
pictorially because we can't draw the
arrows if n is greater than 3 but notice
that what we're saying is that for X to
be near a all we're saying is that the
magnitude the magnitude defined this way
the magnitude of X bar minus a bar is
small in other words when you're adding
up positive squares the only way the sum
can be small is if each of the factors
is small but notice what these factors
are except for the square it's the
difference between X 1 and a 1 X 2 and a
2 etcetera xn and a n in other words to
say that X bar is near a bar means that
X 1 is near a 1 X 2 is near a 2 etc and
xn is near a n which is exactly the
traditional approach and in fact except
for the fact that we can capitalize on
structure notice that once we define the
magnitude of the difference between two
n-tuples do you notice that by the way
the magnitude of the difference of two
n-tuples is a number notice now if we
replace this fancy phrase which we
didn't know the meaning of before but
which we now know by its new definition
we obtain the traditional definition of
limit namely the limit of f of X 1 up to
xn as X 1 approaches a 1 etc and xn
approaches a and equals L means that
given epsilon greater than 0 we can find
Delta greater than Z
such that whenever the square root of x
1 minus a 1 squared plus etc xn minus a
n squared is less than Delta but greater
than 0 then the magnitude you see these
are numbers here the magnitude of f of X
1 up to xn minus L is less than Epsilon
in other words this definition here
happens to be the traditional definition
okay but the point is that the
traditional definition has exactly the
same structure as the modern definition
and as a result to make fun of the
traditional math because it's not as
pretty as the modern math is the wrong
thing to say
alcaman it's like the fellow once asked
me the PTA meeting
how much is 8 plus 7 and the new
mathematics that part hasn't changed the
beauty of using the end couple notation
was that it allowed us to use the
previous structure of limits so that we
could get all of our theorems all of our
formulas and what-have-you to go through
word-for-word even though the higher the
dimension the more complex our
computations are but structurally it
essentially boiled down to after you've
seen one dimensional space
you've seen them all that was the big
innovation with the modern approach to
n-dimensional vector spaces and to help
put this in proper perspective next time
I shall introduce the calculus of
several real variables in terms of the
more traditional approach but again
until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate